so when you have multiple emotional
traumatic scenarios happening at the
same time your reaction can be the same
as someone messing up on the battlefield
that is they freeze they freeze they
don't do anything or they try and solve
all the things at the same time same
thing can happen in the business I don't
know what to do what should I focus on
and they don't do anything or they try
and solve all their problems at the same
time life the same thing can happen so
when we as humans get hit with multiple
emotional attacks or like psychological
attacks you know it's like you lost your
job you lost your girlfriend you found
out that you've got some sickness that's
going on and all those three things
happen at the same time and then on top
of that you find out that you're sick
and then on top of that you know the the
mortgage is due and now you're a couple
days late so these are like problems but
they're not just they're not just normal
problems they're emotional problems and
they hit you at an emotional level